you've been on the show a few times
we're excited but tonight I think it's
the first time ever you're singing on
the show what are you giving us I'm
gonna give you my new song find it yes
is it off your new album closer to the
truth yes like some sort of
questionnaire and it's like I've got the
facts
obviously you don't you're asking me
you're pretty but now I like you tell
you it's for classic I feel we're
getting classic share tonight
what do you mean the classic it's
classic share well you're kind of
getting tartan and well there's a bit of
a punk that's a punk age engage but nice
dark hair that is it a mood thing do you
wake up and decide which share you will
be are you out of your mind tonight
about the explicit content of Fifty
Shades and you know the things but
nothing that Julie Walters hasn't seen
Becky Law personal services oh yeah
[Applause]
really ahead of its time in and all this
stuff in there the all the long all the
fetishes
oh yeah no old Cynthia it was about
Cynthia Payne the madam and yes she'd
seen it all and most of it wasn't to do
with sex it was to do with sort of role
play first time I met her was in a sort
of sheshe restaurant in Soho really
quiet with with Terry Jones you know
from Monty Python was directing it and
she walked in and there was a few diners
in there already quite first thing she
said she didn't even say hello she said
do you like sex journey because you can
find a girl who likes sexual [ __ ] gold
she sits down she gets out a whole load
of photographs and the first one and
they I mean really I'd never seen
anything like me in my life and the
first one was this man lying on the
floor covered in sort of some sort of
dark matter and she said that's my bank
manager dust it's what he liked so he
would pay to go and see her to be
covered in Hoover dust and that's what
and that was discover that you get
turned on by Hoover does if you need a
cleaner just ring me up and I said why
well because I'll get you a slave I have
slaves people come specially to be you
know beaten and do the cleaning so so if
you want somebody all you've got a dozen
to beat someone should all you've got
he's get dibs I'm a toothbrush tell them
to clean the kitchen floor and kick them
at the bun in a pair of high heels and
that it's lovely to have you here it's
particularly after a view because
earlier this year I don't know if you
remember this there was a bit of a scare
bit of a rumor went out that you weren't
here you must have not you seen this it
was where a Twitter hashtag went out and
people already said yeah people guys
read it yeah do you remember this
well no someone told me well this was
the hashtag and it was when Margaret
Thatcher died but in America people just
add it like now that cher is dead
there were a lot of people tweeting yes
I got there was a big Twitter fast it
was trending she's dead this happens a
lot with the hashtag e thing yes so for
instance I don't remember Susan Boyle
Susan the lovely singer Susan Boyle
she was launching a new album and she
was going to have a party and there was
much excitement when she announced her
party
[Laughter]
for a ticket
but these are my favorite one I think
like what were they thinking so there's
a very posh event here called the
Cheltenham literary festival
so the Chaplin misery festival kind of
odd yeah we must be let's get involved
in this whole Twitter thing let's be all
over it yeah we like writers and books
and things but we really need people so
they came up with a Twitter name for
themselves with a Cheltenham literary
festival here it is
sadly attendance is very low no good
find
I have to rap in the Harry Hill film
after it's really hard to learn
yeah it's well that's what it's stuck in
my head hard to learn it is why I'm
calling that place I'm just laughing
because I've only seen clips I hope it
does look very funny every kid makes me
laugh a lot we're seeing one later
what's your rap do my rap is about black
balls yo give me fun sea and Sun hot dog
in a bun just be quick drink on spit
honey you can go now you were done
though
Tony
[Applause]
and of course I think it's exciting
because after all these you're in a
movie with Meryl Streep again yes yeah
cuz Silkwood who's your first movie
wasn't it yes yeah and and I've heard
you talked about how you know some
actors were a little [ __ ] about the
idea of Cher going out acting it was
terrible actually I went Mike Nichols
called and said they're playing the
trailer at some movie you know in
Westwood and you've got to go and see it
so I said oh I'm so excited
so I actually didn't do that but I was
very excited so my sister my friend and
I ran to see it we're sitting there and
it comes up and they show some clips and
then they um say you know Meryl Streep
and everybody applause and then they say
Kurt Russell and everyone applause and
then they say Cher and everyone started
laughing oh and it was just it was
heartbreaking but all I kept thinking
was you know everyone did it so it's so
organic it's so it was just it just was
the truth and so I was I got home and I
called him and he said they may laugh in
the in the beginning but they won't be
laughing at the end I have true they way
I got nominated for Academy Awards
people young actors out there should
take solace because although the success
was very fast and everything not all the
auditions went that brilliantly in the
beginning do you know the one I'm
talking about
the one with Dino De Laurentiis Oh
auditioning yes yes yes well that was
for King Kong no yeah yes the girl she's
very good yeah that was Dino De
Laurentiis senior and his son had seen
me in a play and so I went up to the top
of the Gulf and Western building that's
like the 33rd floor and he had this
amazing office that looked all over
Manhattan and he was back there
and I walked in and and his son was
sitting there very excited that he
brought in this new actress and the
father said to his son in Italian cuz I
understand tiny said gay brother you
know why do you bring me this ugly thing
very sobering so I said to him me this
Piazza Motoman you know but I understand
what you're saying I'm sorry I'm not
beautiful enough to be in Kings car
[Applause]
[Music]
you